donald trump weigert sich standhaft
zweiter zu sein und seine niederlage
endlich einzugestehen
es ist wirklich nur noch albern joe
biden liegt mittlerweile mit über 5
millionen stimmen form an seiner seite
die erste vizepräsidentin kamera harris
er 77 56 kindles wurde auf ein merkmal
konzentrieren job ist um beides alt
anyway
in wirklichkeit ist der sohn natürlich
topfit und das beweist er uns auch in
dem er wirklich zu jeder rede völlig
sinnloser weise ans pult djakpa meter
geschafft hat ich schaffe das jedoch
nicht es ist gerade eine ganz ganz
kritische phase gelder die das beiden
themen jetzt schon dringend bräuchte
werden von der tramp regierung stuft
nicht freigegeben die boykottieren die
machtübergabe hat es noch nie gegeben
und viele drum fans weigern sich
ebenfalls die realität zu akzeptieren
hier zum beispiel der legendäre tv
prediger kennes copeland hahahahaha
hahahaha
hahaha
h
[Applaus]
hh hast du heute morgen deine pflicht
genommen oder was
und wenn sie jetzt sagen na und doch
bloß irgendein verrückter möbel priester
denn beim lachen der kalk aus der hose
rieselt von wegen von wegen meine damen
und herren trump selber verhält sich ja
exakt genauso wie die flitz bibel hier
der denkt überhaupt nicht daran in rente
zu gehen und die gehirn gewaschene trump
sekte formerly known as republikaner
macht auch noch mit bei dem armseligen
putschversuch hier mörder gag vom
außenminister der ubs wird einen
geschmeidigen übergang in eine zweite
trump regierung geben wir sind bereit
die fahrer copeland sagen würde
hahahahaha gar nicht witzig überhaupt
nicht witzig da wird mal eben das
vertrauen in die wahl also den zentralen
akt der politischen willensbildung
durchs klo gespült zerstört dabei gibt
es bis heute keinen beweis für
wahlbetrug das sagen heute nochmal alle
relevanten us behörden sagt auch die
oecd
was beweisen donalds leute denn als
nächstes wahrscheinlich dass joe biden
eigentlich in kenia geboren ist und
muslim kurz danach finden sie
zehntausende ermordete brieftauben die
alle stimmzettel für trump im schnabel
haben sie entdecken dokumente die
beweisen dass joe biden damals lincoln
erschossen hat und am schluss zeigt der
donau noch mit einer pro familia puppe
wo onkel jo ihn angefasst hat trump
dominiert absurderweise immer noch die
republikaner mitt romney nennt in denen
und ich zitiere 900 pfund gorilla in der
partei 900 pfund hat er abgenommen
der psychopath will jetzt nur noch chaos
stiften ist der einzige plan
damit ihnen der supreme court vielleicht
doch noch irgendwie rettet oder sein
anwalt rudy giuliani
das ist wirklich einer der besten
anwälte die noch ans telefon gehen wenn
donald anrufen der rudi verfolgt jede
menge heiße wahlbetrugs spuren eine
führt direkt zum toten vater von will
smith der vater von zwölf hat schon
zweimal hier abgestimmt hat er tot ist
sie weiß nicht wofür gestimmt hat egal
will smith toter vater hat zweimal
abgestimmt für wen wissen wir nicht denn
er schweigt wie ein gramm giuliani
verbreitet seien schwachsinn gerade auf
allen möglichen kanälen teilweise mit
sehr überraschenden wendungen inklusive
werbeunterbrechung sagen sie wenn ich
dass man für so ein anwalt geld bezahlen
muss
sagen sie mir dass juliane keinen fall
schaden hat apropos schaden wenn sie ein
gutes mittel gegen reizdarm wollen valko
flux reizdarm pro ich nehme selbst ja
für als letztes aufgebot was für eine
trümmer truppe aber wer weiß vielleicht
ist dann als verhalten ja auch normal
für sein alter oder für seine
entwicklungsstufe das kennen wir noch
aus diesem kinderbuch klassiker wenn sie
denn auch conny ist wütend ganz tolles
buch gerade ist die fortsetzung
erschienen die heißt toni ist wütend
ronny ist wütend denn alle sagen er wäre
nicht mehr präsident donnie fühlt sich
aber noch als präsident sogar fox news
ab donny wer nicht mehr präsident
vielleicht müssen wir doch auf meint
sein dicker justizminister das hätte er
echt nicht sagen sollen
ihr kriegt mich niemals raus vorher
ziemlich die bude an
gesagt getan und kauft euch auch das
nächste buch das heißt dort sitzt im bau
[Musik]
hoffentlich endete albtraum spätestens
mit beiden vereidigung im januar
insider munkeln ja schon trump könnte
2024 nochmal antreten
was für einen absoluten
niederschmetternde vorstellung wird
donald trump das weiße haus jemals
freiwillig räumen gescheit mal live in
die us-hauptstadt zu albrecht humboldt
er ist immobilienmakler bei engel &
völkers filiale washington warum wollt
dann ist der schlüsselübergabe hören sie
bloß auf ich hatte beruflich schon mit
den schlimmsten berliner hausbesetzern
zu tun
ich habe freunde in leipzig connewitz
aber diese trumps sind wirklich die
hinterletzte nazis wie so eine
fleischgewordene rtl2 reportage haben
sie mein aktuelles foto aus dem oval
office gesehen das stinkt da inzwischen
derartig in der zugemüllten bude
da trauen sich wirklich nur noch die
waschbären rein geisteskranker messi
dabei habe ich so tolle nachmieter
gefunden die beiden reizende senioren
die beiden beiden wollten gestern schon
mal aus messen ob ihre ganzen
billy-regale da auch rein passen ich
also in trams büro ganz höflich habe ich
gesagt ja hallo ministerpräsident im
mietvertrag läuft aus die neuen würden
gerne mal ausmessen und dann der direkt
sofort aggressiv das ist alles nur noch
würdelos der spiegel schreibt trump habe
sich wütend vor den fernseher verkrochen
mitarbeiter hätten im weißen haus
originalzitat duftkerzen angezündet um
den gestank des fast foods zu vertreiben
dass sich trump liefern lassen
wenn der orangen erhöhen troll raus ist
dann da muss ich damit keiner durch
glauben sie denn die usa schlittern
jetzt in eine verfassungskrise dass mir
scheißegal ich mache mir sorgen um die
immobilie
trump und seine familie diese
amerikanischen flotte
wissen doch dass sie am ende raus
fliegen also will er vorher noch so viel
kaputt machen wie geht vielleicht tritt
er morgen aus der nato aus in jedem fall
tritt er mir das parkett kaputt er hat
schon die porträts seiner vorgänger mit
edding bearbeitet wie so ein adhs
arschloch kennt das ist nur noch
peinlich
maximaler schaden er wird jetzt alle
beamte rausschmeißen die noch was können
er wird staatsgeheimnisse verraten
sämtliche klos im westflügel sind
verstopft im kennedy ruhm hat irgendeine
popsound den konzern flüge
da ist ja auch egal na gut bis januar
dafür ja noch da wohnen ich muss diese
albtraum familie jetzt loswerden bevor
melania wieder ihre horror
weihnachtsdeko aufbaut
augenkrebs mit jeder minute sinkt der
wert des hauses
ich habe heute erfahren trump hat sich
dem internet 500 polenböller für
silvester bestellt na toll und wieder
die handwerker holen ich habe keinen
bock mehr
albrecht reimold
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da